[Music]
all right thank you very much everyone
so I'm Josh and the other panels are
already introduced I'm going to start
off with just very brief introductory
remarks and then we're each gonna give
short opening statements I'm not sure
how much debate is gonna because I think
actually there's a really interesting
remarkable agreement among many of the
panelists in the broad sense about the
kind of path Iran but what I'd like you
guys to say in your introductory
statement would like you to focus on is
what path I mean so first of all it's a
above the five of us here I'm sure you
know something about each of us but I'd
say or out of the five of us are
actually working on AI you know as one
of our main things Nick has been more of
a thinker about about a broad range of
paths and their implications and so I
want to start off by asking the four the
four people here and I'll go at the end
and say a little bit about my view what
half a GI are you on
yoshua actually just give a really great
[ __ ] explain that so you could you could
summarize it or just a that's right it
was
but what path are you on which means
like what's your goal and what's your
roadmap why did you choose that path and
how far along on it do you think you are
or you're part of the community is and
then we'll dig into that a little bit
and think about next step so um Arina do
you want to so I think we all agree that
the there are multiple viable paths to
enjoy and all of them come with the
certain trade-offs in terms of how long
it will take us to get to HR you could
take a particular path and what the
resulting HDI might look like in terms
of things like memory or computational
requirements so when I was making a
choice of which path you the question
asked myself is what is it that I want
each eye to actually look like and for
me I I want H I to do as well as humans
on the National tasks in our natural
world and so for me it's probably
natural to look for inspiration
and of course in our world we know that
there is this numerous examples of
biological intelligence each one evolved
for you can perform optimally in the
tiniest ways of the universe that their
body allows them to explore and we know
that these intelligences are very
diverse range from the distributed brain
of the centralized brain of the
vertebrates but also they share quite a
lot of similarities so for example if
you look at the human brain then we know
that cerebellum is shared with the
ancient ancestors like fish and parts of
the limbic system are shared with
lizards also if you even look at the
different areas of the cortex in a
single brain
it's widely agreed that they share a lot
of computational principles and what
architecture even though they might be
doing very different roles like visual
cortex person or district or sex
so it seems like there are some core
computational principles that are shared
between many examples of the existing
biological intelligence that we still
don't really understand so for me this
is the past try to figure out what are
these principles and I'm not talking
about trying to replicate the my new
details of like spiking dynamics kind of
works but what I care about are the kind
of core computational principles so if
you know of Mars way like levels of
description is more of the algorithmic
side things another thing that I think
is really important is that intelligence
does not exist in in the vacuum right if
we had a completely random world then we
would not have so there is something
about the structure of our universe in
the mouth of our world that enables
intelligence to exist so for me it's
really important to examine these
embodied interaction between the brain
and the world to understand where
intelligence comes from so this is my
approach trying to look both at the
structure of the world and the kind for
computational principles
of the brain to figure out what are
these the principles we can then report
to the artificial substrate and also I
think these paths is quite cool because
even if we don't reach HDI hopefully on
the way we can discover quite a lot of
interesting things about ourselves hey
great
go ahead hi my name's E and from Chinese
Academy of Science I'm working on brains
by the approach for artificial general
intelligence so I guess our that one is
quite similar but I do see well I do see
the difference actually well just know
we mentioned that what do we really need
for for the realization of artificial
intelligence do we need spiking patents
activities like that
I understand to my mind I would say that
science is in the detail so my approach
is more on the bringing is part it's
back in your network for for realize
artificial general intelligence so when
we talk to people well people say that
okay you're working on brains by the eye
that means your connection is - and then
I would answer this question like this
so has a connection astre do you reject
a symbolic AI and people always say yes
we don't really need symbolic AI but my
understanding is but is that for brains
by the AI what we need is not only it's
not only the connectors it's not only
the about a computational model and and
their self-organization of the network
but also how can the neural dynamics
give rise to symbolic reasoning so this
is truly important so in this case I
wouldn't say brains by AI is
connectionist so I'm not the first one
to say that like like in 1955 when
people have Western joint conference on
computer science there's a session a
year before the year before the AI first
conference in that Mo's say
water Pete says that emulating the
nervous system and emo and actually
emulating the fight the hierarchy of
final course is traditionally called the
mind will actually come to the same
thing there's no doubt so so in this
case what I expect is that for brain
inspired AI we need this energy and
collective efforts for both
connectionist and symbolic AI but more
in the details I would say so all my
work is based on single single neuron
modeling of different type of neuro and
how it gave rise to different kind of
functions and how this cognitive
function self or self organize together
to realize more of complex multitasking
and even AGI and for more for a more
specific level of detail so we're
working on self recognition different
levels of self-consciousness and fear of
mine so that I think this is a
fundamental use for Safeway I cannot
expect the world that an AGI system
without a sense of self that can really
understand the world and interact with
us so I think the building block should
be starting with very nice show stage of
self consciousness all the way down to
fear of mind cognitive empathy and also
emotional empathy and then we could have
the real safe AI okay great I'll just
say for myself again I think you know
again you saw your show statement we're
all inspired by cognitive science and
neuroscience me you know I come out of
cognitive science and my fundamental
goal is to reverse-engineer intelligence
in the human mind and that means also
the brain but I'm approaching more from
the functional behavioral and I'd say
software level of algorithms as opposed
to starting more from the network
structures and me right now what's
what's what's teams have exciting the
path but I think I'm on is what is in
some ways you know AI is oldest dream
about how to get two qubit intelligence
going back to Turing's paper in which he
proposed the Turing test
right the dream of being able to build a
machine that grows into intelligence the
way a human being does that starts like
a baby and learns like a child that you
know Turing proposed that famously as
the only ID he had about how you could
do it and it's been it's been promoted
by you know out these early AI
conferences by Marvin Minsky John
McCarthy all in some sense all of the
great AI thought leaders from the
beginning and you know Yoshio and I
agree you know very much like we show
the same videos you know the idea of
like what is that basic common sense
that even those young kids have when
they're playing with blocks or cups
right I think if there's a good reason
for this as as a giggling root AI
because it's actually the only known
scaling route in the known universe that
we know actually works right a human
child is the only learning system that
reliably reproducibly demonstrable grows
into adult human level intelligence
starting from monthly so if we could
reverse engineer how that works then you
know that would that would be a route
and it's also a route that we can
measure there are milestones and metrics
and there's an entire field of cognitive
development that has for the last couple
of decades made great strides towards
actually laying out what that roadmap
might look like I'm always asking myself
also okay well if that's what we're
working on and all these great people
have thought about it why why hasn't it
worked before and why is it why might it
work now well I I think we're at a very
important time which is that the fields
of engineering and the fields of cosmic
development have both matured to the
point where they can talk to each other
where engineering just as yoshua said
we're engineering now and offer useful
tools to the people who are trying to
reverse-engineer how babies Minds work
right and where where the field of
developmental psychology hasn't has got
enough qualitative and even quantitative
insight that it can actually start to
guide those goals and hopefully they'll
be mature enough to talk to each other
and in the work I've been doing as a
cognitive scientist for the last 10
years or so that's exactly been doing
we've been building computational models
of instance perception infant common
sense and the learning mechanisms which
take that forward well I mean I'm
excited especially right now about what
I what I see is likely sort of a
moonshot stage for us is roughly the
stage of 18 months
old common sense the common sense that
is that is the height of where we get to
before language comes into the picture
but which language builds on is I think
that's where we have enough
understanding on the stein side and
enough maturity and our engineering
toolkit that we can really you know get
there in a in a practical way we're just
at the beginning of that because then
you'd have to ask well what happens when
language comes into the picture and
culture I completely agree again agree
with yoshua of the sensuality of culture
and the cognitive mechanisms of language
that an end and empathy and other kinds
of things that support that as getting
us you know that's the real singularity
for human intelligence but I think we
understand enough about that first step
that that it's extremely exciting to be
working on that as a computational
cognitive scientist and as an AI
engineer okay so that's so that's so
that's that's the range of views which
in some sense we're all biologically
inspired in some ways of course there
are other possible paths to AGI and
again nick has has had a lot to say
about the different um let's say factors
there do you want to comment on on how
you see the panelists here thinking or
other possible paths I mean I I agree
this looks like kind of the model most
promising I mean may be fun just to map
out things if one sort of indexes say on
unbend your intuitions and vision and
then once these what I could one diverge
from that in different directions and
get different sort of ambitions of this
so I think one one direction would be to
say we need even more inspiration
probality like we really need to capture
the nitty gritty quality that the exact
dynamics of spiking trains and dendritic
compartments and and so forth that could
be a vision somebody would have said we
really focus more neuroscience then may
I and and at the extreme of that you
have people who think we will first get
the machine intelligence by not just
being inspired by the brain but by
replicating the whole thing with some
kind of old brain emulation right that's
what you're gonna work which I agree
looks much less likely but if one kind
of maps out the space of possibilities
that are championed by at least some you
know
non stupid people then that could exist
on that map then I could going in
another direction and say well we can
abstract more from from the brain part
and look more at the mind part maybe
good old-fashioned area looks bad but
there are other ways in which you could
go up a level of abstraction you could
think maybe some kind of evolutionary
algorithm like some algo scourge would
with enough compute to be the way we get
it so like do away with all of this
human scientists trying to figure out
the mechanisms and just hope we find it
in a beginner search base or maybe
something that you find the right kind
of idealization and it's something
different something more principles
something more based in your nature some
kind of graphs something put together by
repeated application of some simple
functions that you build up and and then
this this looks like a clue they do your
letter approach might looks like I kind
of dude you're way off approximating
what there's a cleaner
I guess if you take a more secure
district and say well hey what we need
to do is we are right now kind of
incapable and meet the first enhance
humans either collectively improve our
collective intelligence the scientific
community or individually with
biological enhancement that what would
be what face machine intolerance and so
I think this kind of maps had a little
space and one can maybe put different
people's approaches in there and I have
an impression that that you think
something between Benjo but with a
little bit more maybe theoretical
understanding of the modules and
specific things that human infants do
and then maybe kind of more cognitive
science yeah yeah I guess I I would say
well are you are you yeah no but and
yeah and you might think try to give me
more power and kind of similar in the
level of abstraction of inspiration that
we need yes so if we could talk about
our different levels of abstraction yeah
I think talking about different levels
of abstractions your interesting play
to discuss yeah and I want to comment on
makes point our evolutionary computation
so actually my view for intelligence is
not only about learning what your turn
is like milliseconds to days but also
for decades of development and for
billions of years of evolution yeah
so this is why in max book about like
3.0 saying that for AI we got an
opportunity to rewire both only both
software and hardware so let's say in
the biological brain what we have for
one concrete example is that we have
excitatory inhibitory neural so why not
50 and 50 half and a half is actually
not in the brain well actually in the
sensory cortex approximately 50 percent
of them is you know the mammalian brain
and when I am developing a spiking
neural network for for amnesty
recognition is actually I found that the
15% of the inhibitory is the optimal for
m-mister recognition so that means
through decades of evolution what we
found what the biology found is a
optimization procedure that helped us to
find the optimum to solve problems so in
this case now we got the power of
learning and development and also
evolution so that you can rewire the
whole system the whole system design and
not only for parameter to me for those
connections of the building blocks but
also to change the building blocks and
how they connect to each other so so
this is very important that you know the
scientific approach looks and says okay
there's adaptive process these you could
call them learning instant across all
these timescales write milliseconds
scale to millions of years of evolution
and with cultural evolution also in the
middle of that right and I think you
know that that might there might be
important differences of opinion there
right like you could say there's another
path right which may be referred to a
little bit that is very well represented
I think in some some parts of deep minds
are in an open ai for example and it's
often put out there as as what people
are may be scared about or excited about
is a kind of evolution the sort of
massively distributed deep RL as a model
of a synthetic model of evolution so
what we're going to
this evolutionary process with enough
games you know whether it's dota or
capture the flag or the entire open AI
gym universe and you know that I think
that's it that's it that's an
interesting thesis that that that
toolkit might be able to in some sense
get a kind of evolution but then there's
a question of can I do enough of the
like structural reek construction and
reconstruction that biological evolution
has done that you're pointing to and you
know that there there's more questions I
think um add a few things first of all
regarding the different paths that you
mentioned I think some are safer than
others I think you know this conference
is a lot about safety and in particular
I believe that if we more or less stick
to the human-like intelligence we end up
with something much safer than other
options because we kind of know the
limitations of human minds and they're
not infinite even if we as I said if we
have bigger minds and so what one thing
that's connected to this which i think
is also a good engineering reason for
going that way it's connected to what
karena was talking about when she talked
about the sort of shared principles
between intelligence in different
animals and presumably those principles
if we were to understand them would
allow us to build intelligent machines
now there's you know those you can think
of those principles like a small set of
laws like the laws of physics that would
be amazing I think it's like an amazing
hypothesis if this was true that we
could understand intelligence with such
a small set of principles then it would
have amazing consequences it would be of
course aesthetically pleasing but also
it would make it much easier to build
smaller machines which could be a good
thing or a bad thing but but it would be
mostly building a kind of intelligence
very close to human intelligence and the
other thing I want to mention is about
the levels of abstraction so the reason
I chose to do neural nets in the early
90s early 80s mid eighties was because I
felt that they were at the right level
of abstraction
sort of low-level notions of how like
particular neurons are actually
computing and high-level cognition in
the sense that with the the neural net
toolbox and especially the ones the one
we have today we can we can represent
high level cognitive computation and we
can also represent low level things like
one of the things I've been working on
is how could brain do back prop so low
level computation that gives rise to
credit assignment all of these things
can be talked about in that language so
that's that's that's very convenient one
thing I want to mention also about those
principles there's there's a lot of
effort in neuroscience and maybe to some
extent in cognitive science to describe
our human intelligence through all of
the things that we can do and in case of
neuroscience we like which neurons are
doing what sort of mapping out sort of
huge encyclopedia of every function that
the brain computes where it's done and
you know how things are connected to
each other I think this is hopeless
right it would take forever to
understand the brain that way if instead
we can figure out you know a small set
of principles that can give rise to this
computation then of course it would be
much simpler much faster to understand
the brain and and you know the principle
number one is learning right that that
you don't need to actually describe the
function computed by the brain you don't
need to need to describe which is like a
huge number of bits right you only need
to describe the learning procedure which
could be very very small number of bits
which could fit into your genome I think
I think I think I see the pre-linguistic
stage really important of course and
most animals are there yeah exactly and
I believe that the reason why children
have this amazing vocabulary spurns
because they already pre build the
concepts and now the fastest classes
just like fast attachment of poor labels
to these resistant concepts and I think
if we take AI know
human roots we have a danger of the eye
learning different kinds of concepts
than what and then it might actually be
harder for you to learn they like our
symbolic kind labels for for these
concepts which also means that then
humans might struggle to actually
communicate with AI so then we might
actually struggle to those things the
constrains rights with their
interpretability constraints that come
from that so I think that's kind of a
point I think I think that's a great
point
yeah I mean I think that if we want AI
in general whatever really form is going
on inside but if we want AI to live in a
human world to live safely effectively
valuably right to be able to be an
entity that humans can talk to teach and
trust the way we do with other people
even people we haven't met before then
in some sense right at least there's got
to be something like a human-like API
and at least in some in some sense just
as we have certain API to each other
right there better bit of justified by
some common mechanisms at some level I
think it's it's it's a root not only
both just both to safety but also to
some of the other dimensions of benefit
um maybe just to try to create some
controversy I don't know how much time
we have how much time should we take oh
okay okay great
um well okay so so so I can throw some
good traversable but let me just first
respond to what Nick said what you say
if that's okay and that'll try to create
good and then you can you can you can
hunter great controversy around that you
know like that controversy
so just to say yeah I mean I I think
there is one difference is I guess
coming coming as a cognitive scientist
maybe as opposed to a neuroscientist
there's a there are a few sort of
stylistic differences well I mean it's
also related to our orientation towards
the classical AI right I mean I you know
I think yo should thinks of classical AI
as well they had certain goals but it's
right right
mechanisms really I guess my you know my
feeling and I think that the sort of
collective insight of the field of
cognitive science is that actually
symbols are important there are really
symbols in the brain there are really
symbolic languages of abstractions
symbolic systems in the brain
and it's remarkable how that works and
we don't
know how it works but that there's
actually a lot of success we can have
with the combination of several ideas
rather than say in case of need you know
I wouldn't say neural networks are the
universal representation layer I would
say programs are the universal
representation those programs would be
differentiable programs of the sort that
a deep neural network is but they could
also be you know lists expressions they
can be grammars and I think to me what's
what's remarkable about the maturing
engineering toolkit is our understanding
of all the different possibilities of
programs as models and as different ways
to learn programs right if your models
in general are some kind of program then
learning has to be something like
programming and one way to program is to
is to you know it's the right code by
hand
another is to like as we've now to you
know found have a big differential
architecture with lots and lots of
parameters set up the right data set and
if it's end-to-end differentiable then
you can effectively tune and shape the
program using stochastic gradient
descent and such method but there are
many others but there's no programmer
that programs exactly but one of the
maybe one of the most exciting things in
machine learning right which has been
somewhat independent of deep learning
but is now also drawing on things from
deep learning is what's sometimes called
machine learning meets programming
languages or you know programs that
write programs so these are people
coming with a different technical
toolkit you know from the design
programming languages and program
synthesis and code that writes code it's
it's interestingly also somewhat related
to older ideas of genetic algorithms of
genetic programming but it's but it's
different from that it also draws on
some Bayesian tools but it's different
from that it draws on some techniques of
programming language design and even
spec means from compilers so I see that
area for example there's a hub that
match with evolution of intelligence in
animals and humans right yeah I mean I
think I think it matches very well right
I mean DNA is code right and a machine a
body and a brain is a machine that
builds itself from some code one and one
of the things that does is it writes new
programming languages both individually
and collectively so I think that that
general idea is actually a very powerful
one and and they're the many different
versions of it and correspond to the
different kind the different like scales
levels of analysis and scales of
adaptation
process these including learning
biological evolution cultural evolution
I mean that's a very big picture but I
think it's just that's one key
difference yeah yes so I totally agree
that programs are incredibly important
especially for human level intelligence
but I wonder what you think about this
idea that there are different levels of
intelligence abstract reasoning that
programs is kind of topside with that
but below that we have more kind of
grounded perception based abstractions
and I think there was an interesting
experiment by a little bear where he
kind of traveled around Russia at the
beginning of the 20th century asking
people kind of abstract reasoning
questions like you know giraffes don't
live in big cities Moscow is a big city
with maybe a draft there and people
could not answer this abstract question
they they were like well they were only
basing answers on their personal
experiences like I've never seen the
dress I can't answer this question so
and it seems like essentially this kind
of reasoning wasn't present in people
who didn't have formal education and it
seems like the formal education is what
gives people their bill that's one kind
of programs that's like the
consciousness prayer that's like
symbolic propositional programs but
there's lots of other programs in the
brain that I think we want to think
about how to make perception really work
right I mean in my view and grounded lie
mal I'm all for grounded language as
well but I think it brought excuse me a
broad view of programs that embraces the
strength of deep learning together with
the idea of generative models and you
know symbolic abstraction I think that's
also that's also the key to perception
and grounded language but you know
that's my view I think an another
interesting difference though is the
relation of the engineering enterprise
to the scientific enterprise yeah but
part of that is like how much scientific
detail matters does the whole connect
don't matter the spiking matter and so
on but the other is what's there what's
the relation between the experimental
world and sort of theoretical
engineering toolkit and a nice thing
about hogging the science is that you
know as opposed to the neuro approach is
that I can do those experiments in my
lap or on Mechanical Turk I can work
actively with people studying infants or
young children and to me that's
important it's important to say okay
when I say I want to build a machine
that starts like a baby and learns like
a child it's not simply nice my
intuition about how children think which
is you know Marvin Minsky as brilliant
as he was you know he was either stating
his
intuition or Piaget is intuition but
that you know Piaget was more or less a
contemporary of Turin a lot has been
discovered in the last couple of decades
and baby's brains it turns out start
they're not blank slates they start with
a lot of structure and learning is a lot
more sophisticated than and a lot more
diverse and a lot more symbolic we think
then simply you know understand and
that's the science the guy I have the
impression that what you're proposing is
to use the formalism which seemed
naturally adapted to system to
computation in order to explain system
one computation no I'm again I don't I
don't want they don't want don't I don't
want to miss communicate here right when
I say programs I don't simply mean less
programs right I mean a broad thing
which includes which includes deep
networks right I mean you know these
days in my group we do a lot of stuff
with deep networks and we and one of the
things we do is we use deep networks to
guide the construction of the symbolic
layer right and I think that's very
exciting um so I just to be just to beat
I want to be controversial in the right
ways but I don't want to miss
communicate I'm not saying oh we should
do what we should go back to symbolic a
I'm saying they had a good idea you guys
had a good idea to Judea pearl had a
good idea and and we have a maturing to
look at that allows us to see how these
several good ideas absolutely get
together and actually can extend each
other I mean I think that this embolic
is crucial but I've coming towards the
end rather than the beginning you have
to build up to it you have to sort of
earn your symbols by first sorting out
maybe on symbolic representation and
good old-fashioned EIS a little bit like
if you might in some very low-tech
primitive tribe this is like it just
plain shooting across the sky and I say
we want to build that so they're gonna
record we want this high-tech
civilization and have put together like
some wooden replica right it's never
gonna fly the way to actually get there
is the first invent simpler technologies
and then eventually our factories no
electricity and you can you can do the
whole thing but it's still helpful I
think when doing this upstream balling
stuff to know what you're aiming towards
because it
that you can have constraints in the
kinds of grounded representations you
crave if you know that in the end they
have to be combinatorial that's what I'm
proposing is that actually the the needs
of system to computation can be used to
help system structure right I think is
yes that would be a great idea because
you want it feel free to get you guide
the questions I love to how you guys on
the panel put yourself on the spectrum
of how brain inspired you wanted your
path to be from very little to very much
and I would love it if you can also
place yourself on a different axis in
terms of how intelligible you're
guessing that AGI is going to be where
one end of this expect would be to say
something like well it's just gonna be
ml all the way plus a bunch of clever
new tweaks but it's gonna be a
completely opaque black box will have a
very little clue of how it actually
works there's something maybe more
closer to what josh is saying where
maybe there is a lot of Goldfine sort of
married into that maybe a lot of Josh's
system too so that we can understand
more but but but there's gonna be both
right so if you look at humans and the
system one system to distinction there's
gonna be part of the explanation is
gonna be hard to express in words and as
a part of it which is higher level which
gives probably a good approximation of
the kind that humans communicate with
language and but that's not going to be
the complete explanation unlike what you
know go Phi was trying to explain
everything with with symbols to to
explain our actions or complicated
decisions there's going to be a part of
it that remains difficult to communicate
that's what I believe so I think my view
is that the what perception does in
biologic intelligence is exactly
grounding the symbols and then
everything even system one would then be
built on top of
so it's kind of disentangled
representations that the perception of
eels first and then you can do all sorts
of things on top of either model-based
planning or both for URL so even model 3
might be more in chapter 2 than just
black box but some some things remain
out of reach of interpretability think
about trying to explain the go moves of
alphago right maybe you can come up with
it was if it was trained with constraint
of having system to type of
representations at a high level you
might come up with some the same things
you find in a go book but it's not
enough to completely you know learn as
well I don't think I mean again I agree
with what you're saying on the other
hand explain ability is a key part of
human intelligence right the way if you
the way they seem complete right it's it
exactly I agree with that but we
shouldn't underweight its importance and
especially for a twin a human yeah right
when a human player learns go they learn
those explanations from the go book or a
master are crucial from the very
beginning and if we want a machine if
our goal and stay go or any other game
is to build a machine not that
ultimately with incredible amount of
compute learns to do this one thing at
superhuman level but can learn you know
more with the data complexity as you
said and the time complexity of a human
to learn so many different things so
quickly ok then I think explain ability
is going to be a key part of that I'm
both the input and output side and I
think again maybe we don't just agree on
that those things in terms of that's
like the endpoint of the path but in
terms of where the paths are in the near
term this this is where there is some
difference you know you got you're
talking about earning your symbols I
think in in certain ways that I that are
not fully appreciated in the deep
learning community we already have
earned our symbols there's already quite
remarkable things that we can do with
symbols and the deep learning people's
many of them are doing it anyway they
just don't they like tensorflow
or pi torch symbolic languages that
allow you to build that about individual
to build deep learning systems and that
allow collectively the cultural
evolution process of what you call the
deep learning community to innovate so
quickly in water up very much like
exponential it early exponential growth
counts and you can measure them in
people's
Google Scholar and and steered into
impact on the world okay that that's
those are cultural evolution processes
which of course we don't know how to
completely engineer those things in
artificial systems nearly at least those
symbolic Costas T's at the scale but if
you look at what's going on right now in
other parts of the AI community we have
actually made real progress in machines
that write code or machines that do
probabilistic inference in code so in
the short term I believe that it's not
just the thing we're gonna get to that
we're gonna have to earn and somehow is
going to emerge out of network right now
it is also on our route to building
explainable AI and to understanding the
explainable parts as well as the
unexplainable parts the more intuitive
parts of human time I wanted right maybe
we should hear your echo directly to max
problem that about how optimistic we are
for brain sparta AGI let me give you a
very simple example but very intuitive I
think I think you talked about how
optimistic are you about explainable
we're all really optimistic
I'm actually not not for the long term
because the examples like this I have a
two and half year old girl there's one
day when she said dad I'm gonna be a bad
girl I said what I'm gonna Punk you
I said no don't don't touch dad out I'll
get hurt so she sought a little bit and
then so this is why I want to bring
actually I am bringing my mind cognitive
empathy to my robot so that it can get
some autistic behavior so so I am really
worrying that once we have a model as a
brain spider cognate avenging that that
have general intelligence for as a human
brain in a developmental a way but one
day even with autistic behavior
she said II I'm not gonna do this
because I don't want to follow you
because people people do that starting
from year one they can they can they can
have their pre thinking saying I'm not
trying that oh so this is why III feel
we still meet some dangerous point
another example is humor
humans good of them from the broader
sense but talking about bias who have
bias human so when when simulating or or
building you see there's clouds there's
risks or there's limitations human
cognitive brain inspired so we should
study the neuroscience and cognitive
science of bias and how to avoid that
kind of a building block in how to
understand you well some of them might
be inevitable I mean and and something
in any kind of inductive system and
others might be avoidable and yet we
have to study them to understand that
yeah let's get more see first off great
great panel and and I like the the
discussion may part about the analogies
and learning from humans and human minds
and so forth and and all the advantages
of that I want to just give some counter
arguments in to have you react to them a
little bit and let me just first off
stipulate I understand that there does
exist this proof and there's some
benefit from the biology and it is arena
stead it makes it easier to communicate
and yahshua mentioned briefly that maybe
maybe it's less risky because it's less
likely to be bizarre but from an
economists perspective there are some
advantages to being very different and
first off I mean one of the reasons that
bulldozers or jets are so valuable is
that they have a very different ways of
generating power and so forth and that's
why they're much more valuable than then
then a biological version of those
machines and secondly maybe a little bit
more subtly if a machine is a closed
substitute for a human then it makes
human labor much less valuable
whereas if it's very different
complementary that has superhuman
capabilities and other dimensions but
not on some of the things that humans
could do it's more likely to lead to an
equitable distribution of income and
wealth it's more likely to have humans
still be part of the valuable ecosystem
so it'd be interesting to have you sort
of reacted for those those benefits and
cost of having systems that are very
different from us to versus systems that
closely mimic us and gradually just are
close substitutes so I can mention it
may be the analogy of birds and planes
so it's the same underlying principles
of aerodynamics
right but of course planes look very
different and you might argue that
planes are better in some way but
actually they're just optimized along a
different axis so birds have lots of
constraints of energy consumption that
are not as present for for planes and we
don't have planes that are as efficient
at flying in terms of energy consumption
so I think what's gonna happen is we'll
discover these principles will make
progress and then these will be of
course inspired by animal and human
intelligence but then we'll want to
apply that intelligence to other things
with different constraints than human
bodies have and then I think it will
happen as you say that will move away
towards maybe even before we get AGI
right it's not it doesn't have to wait
for AGI in directions that that are
going to be different that look
different in nature because we push the
in sort of application where the
constraints are different I don't think
I don't think that's what most of the
say deep learning community is doing
we're not trying to mimic humans so
there's a big difference between
mimicking humans as in the details of
what we do of our failures of our
neurons and getting inspiration and
trying to get to keep that inspiration
at an abstract level that corresponds to
where we think are the right principles
and maybe Josh and I could differ and
that's okay we need to explore all the
roots so that's that's not mimicking
right I think that complete the notion
of mimicking doesn't work can I just
come in but with an opinion and
moderation so I agree with points you're
saying both the value and the risk a
value of alternative paths and the risk
of a certain path is mimicking humans I
think another another way to put the
point is that I don't think any of us
are interested in bid or working on
building digital humans but when we say
weird we might there might be some
capacities of humans that we want to
achieve human-level
goals with human-like means
and it's for example common
sensibilities right if we or certain
kinds of social cognition that again
allow us to talk from each other if we
could have whatever kind of AGI we have
if we want to be able to interface with
it if we want to be able to talk to it
and Trust but but but that doesn't you
know that doesn't mean it has to be a
full person I think there is an
interesting point if you're actually
gonna build agents your point about
having a self essential but we don't
necessarily want to build you know AG
eyes that have a full human-like felt we
might want to have all human like common
sense but not a full stuff we might not
want them to have some of the same you
know fundamental motivations and will
that we have we and understanding and in
from an engineering point of view how
that actually works in humans allows us
he's a part of the components and
engineer the ones we want and not the
ones that we don't want to leave that's
one vision so I think that's important
again clear I mean to go back to the
popular bird Erol airplane analogy we
should build airplanes not but some of
the things we're building are also kind
of more like robot earth right like age
you know in some sense agents that like
might lead the flock in the right
direction if there's birds that are
flying or if there's robots that are
flying around with the other birds they
shouldn't be like airplanes because
either the airplanes where the birds are
both will die we've seen that happen too
we're liking this in the self-driving
car analogy we could just get any me
right now if we just if we pass the
global laws that banned all human
drivers and pedestrians and bicyclists
for the streets and said everybody has
to be in a self-driving car it'd be a
lot easier and safer in certain spans to
build autonomous vehicles but because
the route that we seem to be on is one
in which autonomous vehicles have to
live in a human world where there are
humans driving and walking and bicycling
and so on and leaving stuff on the road
and whatever then there's going to have
to be and I think most people that right
now agree that this is a key bottleneck
in autonomous vehicles they're gonna
have to have some understanding of human
intentions so that they can be safe and
valuable in interacting the world and so
that's the kind of thing that we're at
least I'm talking about that can be both
economically valuable landscape we need
to differentiate yeah let's let's take
let's look at
I've noticed that in quite a few of the
conferences I've gone through lately the
need to bridge the symbolic and the
neural based machine learning approaches
is is getting emphasized this as one of
the tasks and also that there's this
recognition that at least in the
learning of children that it's much more
embodied than much more robustly
embodied but in us humans evolution
forged us as creatures in which these
capacities are deeply integrated
integrated in ourselves and in our
adaptive relationship to our environment
and so my question is do we really are
we really just looking at these as
individual capabilities and trying to
forge them or do we really do all of
these tasks but don't integrate them
very well in an embodied relationship
their environment so my view is that
there needs to be integration and we see
that humans right we we see how our
language fades how the world right but
at the same time we can't as I mentioned
before which one is really learn
language at the same time as we learned
the kind of basic concepts so it's like
it seems to be this bootstrapping where
we first need to have some basic
understanding the world from which we
learn the symbols which language and
then language is what gives humans
disability to turbocharge our
intelligence because now we can move to
the symbolic domain and manipulate which
we create new structures just in the
symbolic space mainly using programs and
that so that that programs can only
exist in the space but that's the best
way humans kind of start overtaking I I
would say yes very much to what the
things you're looking for I would that's
the thesis that I'm talking about I
already have it very interesting
promising first
towards what you called neural symbolic
integration right it was art exists and
they're very important for embodiment so
you know I recently I found myself
working with a number of robotics groups
and when I work with robotics what that
mutually means is you know they do all
the hard work the engineering but I'm
very proud that a few robotics elaborate
we've published in the last year's a
couple of robotics papers two of them
have won best paper prizes that leading
robotics conferences you know I don't
claim any credit for that but what
they've done is they've actually in
different ways some of them like you
know are using actually sort of you know
basically combinations of symbolic and
the each of them used combinations of
symbolic and differentiable approaches
one of them has no neural networks at
all but as differentiable dynamics like
differential physics dynamics but then a
symbolic planner that basically says
which dynamic modes should you use that
was work at the market you stated in
another one which was worked at on araga
giant a mighty student did working with
Leslie Kelvin and others right was one
where you took an analytic symbolic
thank physics dynamics model and then
added on a neural network to learn the
residuals you can write down you know we
have really good physics engines that we
can write down right now which capture
your very powerful in capturing a range
of different kinds of physical
interactions but they're not perfect and
and there's many things that we don't
know how to capture their way so the
neural net learns the residuals and that
that is a very powerful combination also
that already exists and it's being used
in real robots so another example of
paper that will soon come out in science
robotics by nima is an example that they
plays Jenga that uses probability and
symbols to play Jenga rights but those
are real things that are happening right
now it's incredibly exciting
[Music]